merci parce que nous sommes le premier
parti de france on a une responsabilité
très particulière c'est celle de
proposer des solutions utiles aux
français en disant la vérité il faut
gagner les batailles de la sécurité
quotidienne
il faut aussi dans le même temps
simultanément gagner la guerre contre le
terrorisme islamiste
parce qu'il s'agit bien d'une guerre
d'une guerre atypique qui nous a été
déclarée par des ennemis qui veulent
affaiblir par la terreur la plus barbare
nos sociétés démocratiques
la france est une cible et nous n'avons
pas à nous excuser de vouloir nous
protéger en écartant en mettant hors
d'état de nuire les individus qui
veulent nous détruire
très concrètement ça veut dire que
l'administration pénitentiaire a une
fonction éminente dont il faut avoir
conscience de notre responsabilité c'est
de lui donner les moyens juridiques
budgétaire opérationnel pour participer
à ce travail de protection des français
il ya urgence parce que ya une
accélération de la menace aujourd'hui il
ya deux cent treize individus qui sont
détenus dans les 187 prisons françaises
pour des faits de terrorisme en lien
avec la mouvance b à 10 213 individus et
leur nombre ne cesse d'augmenter
les affaires dont les parquets ont été
saisis dans les six premiers mois de
2000 qu'un sont cette fois plus
nombreuses que sur la même période de
l'année précédente c'est vous dire
l'augmentation l'accélération de la
tendance trois propositions
je vais trois propositions la première
c'est qu'il est absolument impératif de
dimensionner le parc pénitentiaire à
l'ampleur de la menace
on n'a pas aujourd'hui un problème de
surpopulation carcérale en un problème
de sous capacité carcérale 57 mille
places 2
détention pour soixante sept mille
détenus alors que il ya soixante dix
sept mille places au en république
fédérale d'allemagne
elle marque allemande en espagne 90 7000
places en grande bretagne il ya une sous
capacité carcérale et une incapacité
aujourd'hui à prendre en charge
correctement les terroristes et
notamment les terroristes en lien avec
l'islamisme radical
je propose nous proposons les députés
républicains à l'assemblée nationale que
les terroristes soient non seulement
séparés des autres détenus mais isolés
les uns des autres il faut une double
séparation un double isolement et ce
n'est pas aujourd'hui le cas et je veux
ici une nouvelle fois appelé christiane
taubira à revoir totalement le projet
qui est le sien et qui me paraît très
dangereux projet qui consistera au mois
de janvier a regroupé les 28 détenus
terroristes les plus dangereux près de
lille à annoeullin avec des possibilités
de communication les uns avec les autres
ce qui est totalement déraisonnable
imaginez ça veut dire que des détenus
terroristes pourront dans la salle de
sport dans la salle de musculation et
changer les uns avec les autres et
reconstituer en réalité les conditions
d'un groupe de combat tout cela n'est
pas raisonnable
il faut se donner les moyens de séparer
ces détenus des autres mais aussi les
isolés les uns des autres premières
propositions extrêmement je crois
importante est tout à fait différente de
ce que pratiquent le gouvernement actuel
deuxième proposition
il est urgent de mobiliser les
techniques de renseignement les plus
modernes pour détecter analyser
comprendre identifier ce qui se passe
dans le milieu pénitentiaire et pour
cela il faut professionnaliser les
méthodes de renseignement en veillant à
ce qu un service spécialisé au sein de
l'administration pénitentiaire au sein
de l'administration centrale
mais tout autant dans chacun des
établissements il faut qu'un service
spécialisé recueille et analyse leurs
enseignements techniquement ça veut dire
aussi qu'au plan juridique il est
nécessaire que l'administration
pénitentiaire se rapprochent ou
intègrent ce qu'on appelle la communauté
du renseignement
ce qui veut dire en termes de formation
de ses personnels de compétences
techniques de recueil du renseignement
il ya un effort absolument gigantesque à
conduire et qui est extrêmement
important parce qu'il est bien évident
que dans les soixante sept mille détenus
il y as je vous le disais 213 détenus
terroristes mais il ya aussi de très
nombreux détenus de droit commun dont la
perméabilité avec la mouvance djihadiste
est un vrai danger
on voit bien que dans le parcours de
ceux qui sont passés à l'acte il ya
parfois des basculements qui existe et
le renseignement est absolument décisif
pour bloquer cela très en amont
troisième et dernière proposition
il est impératif de réussir à prendre en
charge dans la durée dans la durée les
individus que nous souhaitons écarté
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
faut que vous sachiez que dans les trois
dernières années j'ai découvert ce
chiffre grâce à ce rapport parlementaire
dans les trois dernières années
cinquante six terroristes ont fait
l'objet de mesures de libération
anticipée
cinquante six terroristes ça n'est pas
raisonnable il faut absolument revoir le
régime du coin comme des peines mais
plus encore le régime d'aménagement et
de réduction des peines il doit pas y
avoir de réductions automatiques de
peine s'agissant de terroristes en
particulier mais même plus généralement
de mon point de vue s'agissant de
l'ensemble des délinquants nous n'avons
pas à nous excuser de vouloir écarter
durablement de la société c'est à dire
nous n'avons pas à nous excuser de
vouloir enfermer des gens qui veulent
nous détruire et donc il faut
réhabiliter la peine et la prison je
conclurai d'un mot l'état de droit doit
être fort ce n'est pas un gros mot
l'état de droit doit être fort parce que
s'il n'est pas fort si les faibles s'il
démissionne si le recul il n'est plus
l'état
il n'y a plus de droit c'est la loi de
la jungle l'état de droit doit être fort
et ça suppose aussi un certain nombre
réorganisation de transformation c'est
pourquoi nous plaidons ici et j'en
termine par là pour qu'un grand
ministère de la sécurité intérieure
pilote coordonne feder non seulement les
cent quarante sept mille policiers cher
michel gaudin les 97 milles militaires
de la gendarmerie nationale mais aussi
les agents spécialisés des douanes qui
ont un rôle majeur notamment pour lutter
contre l'immigration illégale et les
trafics de drogue mais aussi les
personnels de l'administration
pénitentiaire il ya une perspective il
faut qu'un nouvel outil opérationnel met
en oeuvre cette politique de fermeté
républicaine qui doit être j'en suis
convaincu une politique d'intérêt
général au service des français
merci